et bien je pense que la réponse se
trouve dans notre aspiration commune
d'être humain à la beauté
qu'est-ce que la recherche du vrai du
juste dans nos actions l'habit fait-il
le moine la terreur est-elle humaine ou
encore les derniers seront-ils les
premiers ces questions étaient
quelques-uns des thèmes de la finale
d'un concours d'éloquence qui s'est
déroulée mardi 6 juin dernier dans le
cadre du programme articulé qui revient
pour une deuxième saison ce programme
propose une formation originale à
l'expression orale pour les personnes en
recherche d'emploi ou ayant des projets
professionnels
après quatre mois d'atelier d'expression
orale avec une dizaine de participants
cette finale du concours d'éloquence a
réuni 8 volontaires qui ont accepté de
se mesurer les uns aux autres on a un
groupe soudé des encadrants vraiment
super c'était vraiment vraiment une
expérience très enrichissante et les
participants n'ont pas travaillé seul un
avocat une professeur de théâtre et une
forme triste dans l'art oratoire sont
intervenus à tour de rôle et de façon
complémentaire pour donner les clés de
la prise de parole et de l'expression
orale un exercice dans lequel les
postures et les silences sont aussi
importants que les mots du théâtre à la
présentation d'un pitch chronométré sur
un thème imposé plusieurs méthodes sont
travaillées pour que l'oral ne soit plus
une épreuve insurmontable au début il y
a un petit peu de retenue bien sûr de
pudeur de retenue on n'ose pas on n'a
pas confiance en soi et ce concours
permet justement de faire éclater
exploser toutes les compétences et
toutes les envies et tous les désirs un
an les candidats défilent sur la scène
du Centre Culturel le Phénix de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes sous le regard
jury de professionnels parmi eux la mère
de la ville une journaliste et un
spécialiste des concours d'arroratoires
un rendez-vous organisé par le
département des Yvelines alors le
département des Yvelines finance
l'intégralité du concours et des
ateliers qui ont précédés et on est
accompagné par un groupe de
professionnels qui sont des travailleurs
sociaux ou des coordinatrices en
insertion professionnelle après le vote
du jury et du public devainqueront
remporté le premier prix mais tous les
participants ont reçu une tablette en
récompense de leurs efforts au-delà du
concours ils ont surtout gagné en
assurance et en compétences pour leur
futur entretien d'embauche ou projet
personnel